welcome to the man of Recaps this is
Ekko in the Hawkeye show we met villain
Maya Lopez who was a top boss in the
criminal organization of Wilson Fisk yes
Kingpin Maya is a deaf Native American
girl who had a happy family until her
mom died in a car accident where she
lost her leg she and her dad moved to
New York where he's a good guy but a
criminal working for Kingpin and Fisk
himself took an interest in young Maya
became her mentor and Uncle one day
Hawkeye in his Ronin phase attacked and
killed her father no but this brought
her even closer to her uncle Kingpin who
made her an enforcer cuz she's a top
tier fighter but she's not as good as oh
who's that yes it's Daredevil they have
an awesome fight yeah oh it's good to
see him in action again but
unfortunately he's not in this show he
just came in for this one scene and now
catching up to the events of Hawkeye he
told Maya it was actually Fisk who told
him to kill her dad so she confronted
her uncle Wilson and shot him in the
face but Kingpin is a tough guy to kill
he survived a bullet to the brain so now
Maya is on the run from kingpin's gang
she goes back to her hometown in
Oklahoma and has homecoming Shenanigans
like meeting up with her cousin biscuits
her cousin Bonnie she was real close
with as a kid but she doesn't even tell
her she's back to just let Bonnie live
her normal life she goes to the roller
skating rank where her Uncle Henry works
but Henry also works for Fist and
shipping Maya wants his help to take
over and become the queen pin but Henry
doesn't want to bring trouble to their
town so Maya goes alone for an epic
train Heist well almost alone her cousin
biscuits picks her up but she didn't
steal anything she planted a bomb boom
blows up F's weapons warehouse now that
random guy from the roller rink captures
Maya to collect your Bounty and Bonnie
happened to come by too so they're both
captured cousins reunited a goofy
British gangster comes to collector but
my's real resourceful makes a gun out of
a rollerblade and manages to escape as
an epic fight throw ski balls at these
dudes but in the end they're about to
kill her when they get the call to let
her go because Kingpin himself has
traveled to Oklahoma to see his Wayward
niece in person and he's not here to
kill her he just wants to talk we get
more of their backstory of how he was
protective of young Maya beat this guy
to death cuz he wouldn't sell her ice
cream and he's like look sorry about
your dad that was just business you shot
me in the face I think we're even now
but Maya I really think of you as my
family I want you to come back and work
for me and be the heir to my criminal
Empire Ma's conflicted but Fisk is a
really persuasive guy who's good at
manipulating impressionable young minds
he pulls out his go-to move and tells a
story when I was a boy he gives her the
hammer he killed his father with but she
doesn't kill him so maybe these two can
be family again but meanwhile M's been
reconnecting with her real family and
she's been having weird visions of her
ancestors it's like yo grandma what's
going on and her grandma tells her how
they're all connected and her own mom in
fact had healing powers so Maya has a
good long think about who her real
family is and she decides to bail on
Fisk but Fisk does not take rejection
well he kidnaps her grandma so Maya puts
on the new prosthetic leg her Grandpa
built and the Chaka inspired super suit
her grandma sewed so it comes down to
the grand finale at the powwow party
where she confronts Fisk to save her
family of course she walked directly
into a trap but now the powers of her
ancestors echo down through the ages to
her and yeah it's not metaphorical she
gets superpow is all right outside the
British gangster is going to blow up the
powwow but luckily your Uncle Henry is
there to stop it and also cousin
biscuits rolls up in a monster truck to
take out the rest of Fisk goons so now
Ekko grabs her uncle Fisk and uses her
powers to get in his mind but she
doesn't want to kill him he really is
like family too so she tries to heal him
of his own childhood traumas it doesn't
really seem like it worked but Fisk does
leave her alone for now on his flight
back to New York the news reminds him
that the mayoral election is coming up
and now it seems like he's going to run
as for my Lopez she's reconnected with
her family decided to leave her life of
crime behind and be a hero now Echo and
that's where Echo comes to an end if you
like this recap hit that subscribe
button for more of the best Recaps of TV
and
movies